[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to my
last and the final episode of Lowenthal
sister Linda furuto from the black
perspective well in the last episode we
have look at the major side lines such
as Bishop to e3 as well as rook to h3
and in this episode we are going to look
at the absolute main line which start
with 11 Bishop to g5 now against this my
suggestion is you should immediately
start the operation in the center and we
are going to play this pneumatic brake
d5 well there are some tricks and traps
exist for example if white foolishly
capture this d5 pawn with the knight
then we have this simple move Queen to
e4 check if white was to save the piece
then he has to play Knight to b3 but
after just one move
AB 6 and what is losing a piece and in
fact the game so capturing with a piece
is right out of the equation the second
bad move I can try over here is Bishop
captures c7 and yes indeed if black
routinely captured this mission then the
resulting position is favorable to the
white camp but no black has the better
move namely D for the point is two of
the white pieces are hanging and again
knight to defy doesn't work because of
this Queen to b4 check so instead of
that many white players save the bishop
pair with Bishop to c5 but as we will
see that these positions are hugely
favoring the black cam and the sequence
goes as follow D capture c3 be capture
c3 and now yup
this wonderful Czech Queen to e4 black
get all of
is material back and the most important
point is even though white is time being
stopping us to castle on the Kings side
this check is quite annoying for the
white cam as he really don't want to
block with the bishop and give another
pawn to the black cam so the natural
response is Queen to e2 but after that
the position gets simplified with Queen
captures a - Bishop captures e2 and now
Bishop to e6 planning to castle on the
Queen side and if somehow white can
prevent this with rook to d1 then we
have always options such as f6 and King
to have seven all together this horrible
pawn structure gives black good
advantage in upcoming endgame so to cut
the long story short by far the only
response exists for the white here is he
captures Levi well here black has two
major choices and my personal
recommendation is night to b4 which is
more consistent with our other recruit
ah
however you can also check out night to
d4 a good alternative which you might
want to consider in the two Naumann
practice and all deacon analyses are
available in the PGN okay night to be
four so black has created the first red
namely night to see to check and
accordingly white has few options
well once again Bishop captures c7 is
the main line but first let's check out
what happens if white try other moves
the first move I want to consider is
rook to c1 well after that black should
continue with AB 6 attacking the bishop
and white can already goes wrong if he
moved the bishop let's say Bishop to e3
because if you have checking out my
other videos
you instantly find this nice reply yup
fish up to a fire and suddenly there is
no way white can save the sea to pawn so
it is very obvious that here white
cannot move the bishop and he has to
play the culture attacking move a tree
okay after that the sequence goes as
follow pawn takes g5a takes b4 and now G
takes h4 well all the game in the
database continue from here onwards with
rook captures h4 and here with the help
of chess engine I found this very tricky
move Bishop to g4 there is a nasty trap
exist here guys if your opponent
continue with f3 which of course looks
very logical but in fact it's a big-time
mistake by white because black has this
dazzling response Bishop captures f3
well obviously white can't take this
bishop the simple reason is after Queen
to g3 check he is going to lose the
exchange so that is right out of the
equation but in the tournament practice
people can easily see there and they
might take with the Queen thinking that
every basis are cover but see yourself
just one move Queen to g5 and white is
going to lose one of his rope
better try here is Queen to d2 but after
that black get huge initiative with
castle on the Kings side now as you can
see I have highlighted by the arrows
Knight to f5 and rook to d8 are coming
on the card and the most important
factor is white King is stuck in the
center I have recently reached this
position against a 2300 rated opponent
and this game will give you a nice
illustration how good black position is
as my opponent continued here with
Bishop to d3 attacking my queen I simply
responded with Knight to f5 so my idea
is when my queen will be moved his rook
can get attacked okay
my opponent continue with d6 so he wants
to put his knight on a juicy c7 square
but unfortunately for awhile there is a
big time tactic in this position
starting with Evo
obviously you can't take with the knight
as you rukon - for is hanging so white
has to by force take with the bishop but
after that now you see the point behind
sacrificing this fawn yup pinning down
this bishop and threatening night to h4
after the accurate sequence from the
both decide d7 black has to take this
bishop now and after Knight takes e4 and
night capsules h4 it turns out that time
being black obtained an extra piece here
d8 queen is a wrong move because Queen
captures efore comes with a check so
strongly enough my opponent continued
with first Queen to defy check and after
Bishop to b6 now he promoted the phone
to the queen we quickly reach to the
endgame after the following sequence
Knight to G to check King to d2 and now
black
take the queen with Bishop captures defy
Queen captures defy Queen to f7 Queen
takes f7 and rook kept step seven if you
count the material at this point we have
a complete balance but if we look in
terms of position point of view black is
in a clear driver seat because of his
unopposed H pawn and pressure on f2 well
after a long struggle black indeed
managed to win this game which shows the
potential of this line the second move I
want to consider is Bishop to d3 well
this is pretty much similar to Bishop to
e3 line as we are getting this position
by force Knight captures d3 Queen
captures d3 Queen captures d3 and pawn
captures d3 first we are going to eject
this Bishop with epics and after Bishop
to e3 remember this time attic plan with
B Phi so idea is very obvious we want to
put up a bishop on b7 and as White has
this week double pawn we can target them
in the rest of the key once again I like
to show you one of my quick blitz
victory in this line where my opponent
continued with castle on the Queen side
I simply responded with Bishop to b7 and
he played d6 okay Knight to a5 and black
pieces are attacking on the multiple
location so I decided that I want to
keep my d6 pawn with Bishop to c5 but as
it turns out that after Bishop captures
G to look to Jeevan Bishop to f3 and
look to even White has just one threat
in this position which black and safely
negotiate with King to f7
and if you carefully look at this
position hi think black is completely
winning why number one s4 is going down
the drain
very quickly number two this double deep
on are never going to be safe and it's
just matter of time where black and put
this rook on the D file and munch the
spawns finally you can also use some
tactics based on the C file and
altogether I think white is really
struggling for any counter play from
this position the third move I want to
consider is d6 well after that if you
are playing a low seed then my
recommendation is you should continue
with Knight to c6 and I have attached a
sample line in the PGN however I think
here by force black and get a draw which
we are definitely interested playing
against a higher seed the sequence start
with nightcaps a/c to check king e2 is
not a good option because of Knight to
c6 and then one of the night launched on
the d4 square so the accurate response
is king to d2 and after that you should
continue with Bishop to a5 well the d6
pawn is hanging and if white continue
with Bishop captures c7 then this is
pretty bad choice the simple reason is
after quintet six check by force
White has to put the bishop back on g5
and after that yup we are going to take
this pawn and not only black emerged
with an extra pawn but white King is
completely stuck in the center which is
always a good sign when you are playing
for the win so Bishop captures c7 is a
pretty bad choice at this position
the most accurate responses pawn takes a
seven but after that first we are going
to give this champ and again White has
to be very careful if we continue with
King to c1 then after queen captain
Stephen King capture Stephen and now
Knight takes even black clearly obtained
an exchange so that's not a good choice
for the white camp and the only accurate
move hearings King to e2
afterwards black should take this draw
faith Knight to d4 check King to even
night to see to check King to e2 and so
on so this is one line guys where black
is satisfied with a draw but still white
has to play some very careful moves in
order to reach this position finally we
reach the main line with Bishop captures
c7 King takes a seven and now as per the
database White has tried mainly two
moves in this position the first move I
want to consider is d6
which surprisingly very bad what white
is hoping his black should take this
pawn with the Queen so that after the
following sequence Queen captures d6
King captures d6 castle on the Queen
side with a check and after King to e7
a3 Knight to c6 and Knight to d5
black pieces and King has been really
pushed back with a good advantage to the
white cam so obviously we shouldn't fall
for all this and instead of dad here my
recommendation is you should play this
very safe move King to f8
well now indeed the see two ponies
hanging and accordingly White has two
choices number one if he continued with
Bishop to d3 then after the following
sequence Knight captures d3 Queen
captures d3 Queen captures d3 pawn
captures d3 now you will see the
significance of playing the MU H five as
black has the star move rook to at six
not only getting the pawn back but there
is a huge time pressure will be built up
on this week backward d3 born probably
the most critical know in this position
is d7 not only hitting the bishop but
trying to checkmate black king with
queen promotion so black responds his
force he has to take this d7 pawn and
the big time idea from the white side is
he wants to capture this bishop allowing
this folk and when black take the rook
in the corner he wants to continue with
Bishop to c4 well you can continue here
with night to c2 but I think those
visions are somewhat unclear so instead
of that my suggestion here is you play
this crafty Queen transition Queen to at
six Jack King to e2 and now Queen to f4
not only defending on f7 but counter
attacking the white bishop and if the
bishop goes to b3 we are going to
exchange with the knight and any other
moves let's say Bishop to d3 we can
deliver this nice tactical blue Evo the
point is after Knight takes e4 rook to
e8 we are getting the centralized night
with the next move have fired after the
obvious sequence F 3 fi rook captures
even pawn takes e4
pawn takes e4 and now the star move
Queen to g4 which forces the Queen train
and gives Blair a healthy exchange
advantage last but not least what
happens if white continue with Bishop to
d3 well I think you are very much
familiar with these positions and you
know the sequence right yup
Knight captures d3 Queen captures d3
Queen captures d3 and pawn takes d3 do
you remember what to do against this
double D pawn congratulations if you
find the moon B Phi so as you can see I
have highlighted by the arrows black has
a very simple plan to execute to attack
this double D pawn and don't forget had
this position black is already looking
to play the move before dislodging
denied and then get the deep own with
Bishop to b7 well so far roughly more
than 10 video games reached to this
position and the majority of the game
continued with a3 stopping any before
movement but even though let's say Y
doesn't play a3 and if we continue with
either move such as short castle or long
castle it doesn't matter to us because
of a plan of campaign will remain same
in order to understand the whole idea I
like to show you a model game between to
2300 plus rated opponents in the game
black continued with Bishop to b7 which
is slightly inaccurate as my suggestion
is you should continue with King to d6
with stops any white knight movement
anyways let's see the game Bishop to b7
has been played and once again 80% of
the game can
Navid castle on the queenside which I
think very logical move what white wants
to do is he wants to centralize this
route and then open up the position with
d4 okay black plays rook to see it
pinning down the c3 Knight threatening
Bishop captures defy and accordingly
white counter attack the black epon with
rook to e8 well we don't want to keep in
the pin for a long time so correctly
enough black plays the King to d6 and
after the obvious response d4 he calmly
defend everything with rook H to eat now
we have few exchanges over the board D
capture C Phi Rho cap to see if I Luke
captures ePHI and king takes e5 where at
the end defy pawn still remain the big
target in the case of g3 black should
respond with Ava and b4 so in the game
white choose the obvious option look to
even chat and after King to d6 it
doesn't matter wherever white moves the
king in order to unpin his night the
next move of the black is very nice rook
to see for not only attacking the week
at full pawn
but when why defended with g3 black
delivered this forcing sequence Bishop
captures defy Knight captures defy you
really don't want to take with the King
as rook to e7 gives white an advantage
but black has this in-between move rook
to d4 chat King to c3 and rook captures
defy we're at the end of transaction we
have a completely equal position with
the same pawn structure and after few
moves indeed black managed to draw the
game
so you can see that even after providing
25 moves accuracy the best white can get
is a draw which is obviously a good
result for the black cam so don't worry
I don't think so any lower rated
opponent will know all of this stuff and
reach to this position and against
higher seed we don't mind any drawers so
this is the best white can hope for in
the main line that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful Lowenthal
de prata from the black side remember
when you opponent continue with Bishop
to g5 play this time attic break in the
center with d5 and after it captures
defy and the Moon Knight to be full
White has to dodge a lot of bullet in
order to survive this position and even
somehow if he study and achieve it the
best result he can hope for is a draw
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next report are very
soon bye and take care